So what if anything you've heard about MMS master literal solution the short name for that is MMS or it's also called chlorine dioxide that's the typical term that they use for now because MMS as a term
master's middle literal solutions as a term that was coined by Mr. Hummel I think his name is and and he had got a lot of address and in my opinion rightfully so because he was making claims that
were outlandish and irresponsible in my opinion and you know it it just it does not help your cause I think even if you have a good product if you start claiming that it cures everything and it's the it's the panacea of all disease I just think that's wrong because there's there is no such thing and when you start making those kind of claims that he made and seminars and you see this at some point
different multilevel marketing type seminars, situations where they make these outlandish claims that they can't back up at all and and I'm not against using anecdotal information when you're when you're talking about a possible solution to a serious disease I'm not against using products that may be
don't have double blind studies done on them I'm not against that at all but you don't make claims I mean I love the right machine but I don't claim that cures anybody or cures and cures any disease when you start doing that you should kind of get trouble with my point of view you don't mislead people.
That's what was happening with MMS we have I have a lot of experience with MMS that's with cancer but we used to see a lot of line patients years ago I had a clinic up in Duluth, Minnesota and it was just it's a big, big area for Lyme disease and MMS works really well to help kill biotoxins like Lyme it is a chlorine type solution
and that's where it gets its bad name. Matter of fact that's what somebody had recommending to President Trump at the time to use MMS and when they explained it to him I have no idea the details of this but I think that's what he was talking about what he made some off the cup comment about drinking bleach to kill Coleman that was complete misnomer.
Misnomer and a misrepresentation of what MMS is it's not bleach it's chlorine dioxide and it's different than than bleach solution but it does have that bleach smell because it's got the chlorine in it and and when it was explained to him the way he understood it in the way he.
Represented in his comment made him look very foolish and he got a lot of backlash from it the sad thing is is that MMS probably would have been a good solution for a person with COVID because I think where MMS shines is in treating a stubborn biotoxin.
So a biotoxin is a is a pathogen of living organism like Lyme disease which is a bacteria and its co infections which can be viruses or like COVID which is a virus MMS could be a possible you know aid for that because it does kill directly it doesn't kill by stimulating immune response it kills directly.
So for people especially people with Lyme disease that have phase three line in an autoimmune situation where they don't want to do a lot of things that will stimulate in immune response which seems to be counter intuitive if you have.
And a pathogen but you but when you also have an autoimmune disease if you stimulated immune response to try to kill the pathogen you will kill that which you have antibodies against first and you will kill self tissue if you have an autoimmune disease so you have to be careful in a phase three line situation there am I using something that will kill directly like MMS.
It doesn't stimulate in immune response and it could help kill directly and it could be a real big aid now we don't see very many Lyme patients anymore we just don't have time.
To do full line plans and to be handling Lyme patients what on what as much as we used to so we don't have MMS on our store we took MMS off of our store we used to sell it.
We took it off our store because it got so controversial FDA was coming after anybody that was selling them the best which is an absolute ridiculous thing because nobody's nobody could you get hurt by anything but you'd have to try to be hurt by using MMS.
And but you can be hurt by taking an entire model of vitamin D I suppose to you can overdose on vitamin D so you can get hurt by doing anything but for the FDA to spend time in taxpayer monies to go after places that are selling product like MMS is is absolutely ridiculous and criminal itself when drug companies have to put you know 30 seconds of disclaimer after a drug add because.
Actually the best studies that they picked out to get FDA approval still showed people with those type of symptoms you realize that when you see those drug ads and they go they cause blah blah blah mom 30 seconds of diseases that it might cause when they do studies double blind studies on drugs to see if they were they literally will send it out to maybe 50 universities to do the studies.
And they have to do a study and they list that they have to have a hundred people in the study or a thousand people in the study and they literally have to list all the side effects of the people in the side of double blind that actually got the drug so and then when they do those 50 studies they may have had they may have had 48 of the studies come back where nobody got better from the drug.
Everybody just had side effects well they don't legally have to publish those studies but they have two studies that came back one from Baylor and one from you know Texas and that show positive effects of that study will they only publish those two studies and then give that to the FDA but they still have to by law list in their ads the side effects that happened in those best two studies.
And that's what you're hearing when they're reading off those side effects so can you imagine if they had to read off the side effects of everything all this negatives from all the bad studies that they even they were so bad that they didn't even want to publish that's how this that's how corrupt the FDA and the drug industry is and then they go after somebody because one person complained they got a headache from taking MMS.
It's just absolutely mind-boggling. There are MMS protocols for cancer it's fairly high dose MMS I cannot see how taking MMS orally would really help anybody with cancer just can't wrap my head around the physiology of that but I can see the possibility of doing MMS topically for cancer more might help I don't know.
It certainly could help I can't even imagine how a chloride solution in the bloodstream would help kill cancer but I do think that there's a possibility but I think it'd be a minute possibility for a topical cancer so this would not be something that I would recommend necessarily high on the list but if we couldn't find anything else it's certainly worth trying because every cancer is different remember
if you have a topical cancer or something that's broken through the surface there's no hard no file in trying different things and if I was in that situation I would try to use as much logic as possible and knowledge as possible but I would be trying different things.
DMSO was talked about in this too DMSO can be used and added with MMS can be added to an MMS topical solution but can be used by itself DMSO is dimethyl cellboxide it is a sulfur type chemical and it can be very anti-inflammatory.
So DMSO became very popular in the 1970s using it topically for shoulder injuries and joint problems and even spinal problems, spinal neurological problems when the problem with the neurology at the spinal cord was inflammatory.
So there was a inflammatory condition even in a car accident victim that damaged their spinal cord and now paralyzed there are case studies where using DMSO over the spinal cord decreased the inflammation and that person was able to walk again to some degree.
So DMSO is a very powerful anti-inflammatory it absorbs like instantly so DMSO is used with a lot of other things to help draw things into the tissues.
So using DMSO we use DMSO in our homemade curfewin cream DMSO can be used in a spray bottle. DMSO is like water liquid like water.
It has some negatives you'll get it smells very garlicky you'll get a garlic taste in your mouth you'll get a garlic smell because it's the sulfur at an oyster taste in your mouth after using it which some people don't like but if it does help them with their chronic rheumatoid arthritis or something else it can be beneficial.
So you can use it as a drawing agent because it absorbs so quickly so if I want to get turmeric into a cancer that's maybe a centimeter deep I can use turmeric surfacedly and then spray some DMSO over the top of it so you can use DMSO to draw other things into the tissue.
But you have to know that and be careful you can't put a chemical lotion on like something like over the counter lotion that has a whole bunch of crappy chemicals in it and then spray DMSO and you'll drive those chemicals into your bloodstream too that's not necessarily good.
So you shouldn't be using those crappy chemical oceans anyhow but for a person that isn't as naturally minded as you guys are they could possibly.
You can simply toxify themselves by using DMSO because it will draw anything in so you want to make sure your skin is clean or then put whatever you want to get into your body on your skin and then you can spray some DMSO over the top of it it's it's a it's a great solution it's you can buy it on Amazon it's very inexpensive.
And that would be something that you could try by itself on a topical open cancer and there really isn't any harm and you can't really hurt yourself with DMSO so it's it's another thing that you could use.